-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy Award-winning actor
you know best as Will Truman
from NBC's "Will & Grace,"
which returns for
its second revival season
this Thursday at 9:00 p.m.
Let's take a look.
-Grace, is Will here?
-I'll get him.
Hey. What's up?
-You are not going to
believe this.
I just saw my boobs
walking down Madison Avenue.
-That's why the little label
on the pill bottle says
do not mix with alcohol.
-Please welcome back to the show
Eric McCormack, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
Welcome back.
-Nice to be back.
-I have to say,
that really speaks to the fact
that you work on a classic show.
With very little context, that
was an extremely funny clip.
-Thank you. Well, yeah.
All you have to do
is talk about Karen's boobs.
-Yeah, exactly.
-And everybody
is paying attention.
-Well, last time you were here
you had just done
a mini reunion.
Sort of small special
"Will & Grace."
This is before
the revival season.
-It was the only thing
we were going to do.
We were going to do
this 10-minute video
to encourage people
to vote for Hillary.
Clearly that worked a treat.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You struck out hard.
People still blame
you guys for it. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
She's not speaking to us.
-Yeah.
-That's why she did Murphy's --
the Murphy show.
But then NBC saw it and said,
"We've got to have this."
So the show became much more
political than it ever was.
It was always very LGBTQ,
very cultural show,
but it was never political,
and so, now we --
we just did a show where
Jack and Will go to Texas
and experience
all of that homophobia.
Meanwhile,
Karen tags along with us
to see the portion of the wall
that she sponsored.
[ Laughter ]
So we get to do that.
-There you go. Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Obviously people over the years
lined up to be guest stars
for the show
and in the revival,
I think people were, of course,
excited to be part of it again.
Are there dream --
Would there be a dream guest
for you to have on the show?
-I've been pitching that Will
has a secret Canadian lover
for the entire -- and it would
be revealed in the season finale
that it's Justin Trudeau.
-That would be great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think he'd be game.
-He'd be great.
-He'd be down for it.
You are Canadian yourself.
-Yes, I am.
-How do you feel the perception
of Canada
has changed in
the last couple of years?
-Oh, it's -- There was a time
when, of course,
Canadians were just cute.
Aren't they cute?
-Yeah, yeah.
-With their snow and their funny
way of talking.
And now it's kind of like,
"You're from Canada?
Like, can we hang out?
We should be friends.
We should be best friends."
-But do you think -- do you
think people here in the States
underestimate
how easy it would be
to just pack up
and live in Canada?
-Well, that was the thing.
Everybody was like, "Oh, if he
gets in, I'm moving to Canada."
And I'm like,
"You know, it's kind of a hard
reservation to get.
-Yeah.
-Right?
Like, you can't just show up.
It's a country.
[ Laughter ]
-You also -- You have
another show, "Travelers,"
that you film in Vancouver.
-Yes.
-It's interesting because
at the same time in your career
you're doing "Will & Grace,"
which obviously,
is a comedy that you have
some comfort with,
and another show
that's incredibly dark
and very different.
Is it -- Is it easy to do
both at the same time?
-Well, I come from rep theater
where you do a comedy
in the afternoon
and a tragedy at night.
So I was really lucky that
Netflix was --
I was already doing the first
season of "Travelers,"
which is a very dark
sci-fi show.
Two seasons available right now.
Go home and watch it on Netflix.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
But we just shot the third
in the spring,
and I had four days
to become gay again.
[ Laughter ]
It actually --
it doesn't take that long.
[ Laughter ]
Really, it's -- it's actually --
-You could turn it around
even faster.
-It's about 10 minutes.
-Okay, got you.
-Anybody can do it.
-Oh, that's great.
-Which was amazing.
I literally had four days off,
and then we were back
on that set.
So it's been a luxury year.
-Your son is 16.
-He is.
-Is he excited --
is "Will & Grace" something
that excites him?
Is he excited about your career?
Is he impressed with you?
-[ Chuckles ]
Well, he -- When we went off the
air the first time he was three.
-Right.
-So, gay sit-coms were not
high on the priority list.
Though he loved
"Spongebob Squarepants,"
which I think is pretty close.
-Pretty close, yeah.
-It's pretty close.
-It's ballpark certainly.
-It's the "Frasier" of cartoons.
-Yeah.
-I think.
[ Laughter ]
But now, he came to set
the other day,
and I thought,
"He's gonna love this.
Now he'll appreciate this,
with the cameras
and Jim Burrows directing."
And I think we got a scene in,
and he was like,
"I got homework to do, Dad."
And I'm like, "It's 4:30."
He said, "No, I got a lot.
I got a lot of, uh, chemistry,
yeah, yeah."
-We were talking backstage.
He was only a few months old
when we first met,
when you hosted "SNL."
-That's right.
-Which is 16 years ago.
-Which you're about to do.
-I'm about to do.
-Which is very exciting.
-Yeah.
Not this week, but next week.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, that was --
-One of the problems --
looking back at photos of us.
This is one of the issues
with me hosting is
I was mostly just
the other guy in sketches.
Here I am.
I am your lawyer in this sketch.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I love that.
-I look like
a very inexpensive lawyer.
[ Laughter ]
Who maybe just finished
law school.
And in this --
I was in this sketch a lot.
There I am right there.
There's me, there's you, Maya,
Dratch, Forte, Poehler.
I was in a lot of dinner parties
in my time at "SNL."
-I think it was your first year,
wasn't it?
-Yeah, it was
first or second year, yeah.
Well, no, yeah,
it would have been.
-You, Fred, and I think
Will Forte.
-Yeah.
You very were kind to us then,
and it's always great
to see you here.
Thank you so much for being
back. I really appreciate it.